COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JUNE
EIGHTEENTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVICE ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING.
PROCEED IS BEING MADE HAS ALSO
BEEN TELEVISED.
PARA SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
SEVERAL PLAYERS [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER GRAYSON HERE
MAYES HERE.
AS AREA SALAS PRESIDENT WALDRON
HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A SURGEON.
UBER MISTER SALAS SECONDED BY.
BY MISTER GRAYSON --
MATHIS SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY.
AYE COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES
AYE FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
KNOWS AREA AND SALAS.
FOLLOWERS AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
PUSHES PAST AND THE SCHOOLS
FRAZIER JOINED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH